[Music]
in the 1970s we had the roe v wade
decision in the United States I was a
decision rating relating to a woman's
right to have an abortion it introduced
the trimester framework it basically
allowed first trimester abortions made
it very difficult to have third
trimester abortions and essentially this
was really met very quickly thereafter
with the sort of backlash and really the
last 4050 years of American history have
more or less been a backlash against her
every wait an attempt to kind of
criminalize abortion and all sorts of
interesting ways without overturning the
decision facially so that's kind of a
legal playing field and we can talk
about some of the specifics but the more
interesting question I think is thinking
about the morality of abortion and I'll
say that I think abortion it's extremely
difficult question so one of the first
questions people have to think about is
are fetuses persons now that's a very
important linguistic question persons I
didn't say human beings I didn't say
alive those are three different issues
right something can be alive but not be
a person your dog is a good example you
love your dog it's a wonderful thing but
it's not a person something can be human
and potentially not be a person right
some people think the early embryo for
example before 14 days or stem cells
being derived are members of the human
species but may not be person so what do
we mean by persons we mean something
that has a certain set of moral and/or
legal rights the most important of which
is a right against in viability they
can't be killed or destroyed or harmed
without very good reason and we have the
attitude that we're all persons right so
we have an index case we're pretty clear
we're persons and the question is who
else is a person well to answer that you
need to have a theory about what makes
something a person and there are a few
different kinds of theories you can have
one could be just to say if X is living
and a human being X is a person right
now some people have problems with that
so Peter Singer and some animal rights
advocates for example think that that's
a speciesist attitude and by saying
human equals person what's problematic
that we're excluding animals instead we
ought to have some criteria that looks
at capacity so other people have some
is what a call to capacity X view where
they say in order to be a person you
have to have X capacity and then we have
to fill in what X is is that the ability
to think complex thoughts the ability to
plan and look towards the future the
ability to feel pain whether you
understand it it's about continuity of
an identity over time or is it merely
being alive and breathing and some
people think it's a single criteria
other thinks it's a compound criteria
and then there are complex questions
about what happens for things that have
the potential to have capacity X or had
capacity X but lost it so for example a
fetus doesn't have the ability as early
fetus let's just say an embryo just to
make it very easy an embryo before 14
days doesn't have the capacity to think
deep thoughts about the future have
future orientation I think that's pretty
well accepted by everyone but it
certainly has the potential to do so
right and the question is is that enough
what kind of theory of potentiality you
know hydrogen and oxygen each have the
potential together to become water but
does that mean that they are water they
have the metaphysical properties of
water or do we require more of a kind of
potentiality something like in the
natural course of things you will become
something the other difficult set of
categories are things that once had the
capacity but now no longer have it and
perhaps never will again so those that
are brain-dead for example are a good
example
they are certainly human beings they
most cases they have been persons but
now if your capacity for personhood how
you define personhood is something like
the capacity think deep thoughts about
the future or to have future orientation
these are entities that no longer have
that capacity and we don't believe we'll
have it again do they cease being
persons at that point these to say that
in order to understand whether a fetus
or an early embryo the kind that are
used for stem-cell derivation is a
person you have to do a lot of
metaphysical work and understanding what
makes something a person and why and
what those capacities are now even if
you think something is a person that
doesn't necessarily mean you've solved
the abortion problem so it is possible
although popular among Philosopher's is
not so popular in the
political press to say fetuses are
persons and yet abortion is still legal
and justified how does that argument go
the suggestion is that there is a right
of another entity that has overcome
whatever interest the fetus has and that
is the right typically of the mother who
is just stating the fetus so the claim
is yes a fetus is a person
yes abortion will cause the death of a
person but that doesn't mean that
abortion is wrong because the woman
gestating the fetus has a right to stop
that gestating even if it will result in
the death of a person and the most
famous version of this argument comes
from Judith Jarvis Thompson a very
famous thought experiment about the
world's most famous violinist and she
says imagine you find yourself I had a
heavy night of drinking got drunk he
blacked out you wake up the next morning
you find yourself a human dialysis
machine hooked up to the world's most
famous violinist nobody doubts the
violinist as a person right he's a good
not only a person a great person world's
most famous violinist but she says don't
you have the right to implode yourself
from that person even if it will turn
out that will result in the death of the
violinist and she says if you think the
answer is yes then you think that even
though the entity is a person you may
have a right to cause its death a right
to unplug itself and she analogizes that
to the right of a mother to unplug
herself from her feet as soon as a
person now there's lots of contestation
about that thought experiment right you
might say you got drunk no fault of your
own somebody kidnapped you is that
really the situation of all women who
become pregnant or is it the situation
only of women for example who are raped
or who are you know pregnant in an
unconscious state but this is just to
show that there's some complexity here
okay one more point that is that the
stem cell question look is different on
this regard remember when we're talking
about embryos we're talking about
embryos that are frozen that are in a
lab nobody is gestating them if embryos
have the rights of persons unlike in the
case of abortion there's nobody who has
a contrary right to stop just stating
them so you might actually think the
argument for prohibition against
destroying early embryos is easier than
the argument for prohibiting abortion
for this reason now the flip side you
might think the early embryos that even
less of the capacity X whatever that is
then does the fetus but this is the way
in which bioethicists and lawyers think
about these problems
[Music]